l'heure est grave vladimir poutine mais
l'europe en danger titre le journal du
dimanche
à quoi joue vladimir poutine demande le
parisien mais la une la plus surprenante
reste peut être celle de libération on y
voit le président russe lunettes 3d sur
le nez regard tourné vers l'espace le
tout chapeauté d'un titre que nous
qualifierons volontiers de culottée
trêve de plaisanterie force est de
constater que vladimir poutine n'a pas
les faveurs des médias meanstream
français et c'est un euphémisme
le patron du kremlin est accusé de
vouloir déstabiliser la terre entière
rien de moins et pas seulement l'espace
également où la russie a détruit lundi
l'un de ses vieux satellites en orbite
depuis
1982 un comportement dangereux et
irresponsable d'après washington pour
qui cela aurait menacé la sécurité des
spationautes à bord de la station
spatiale internationale
moscou n'a pas tardé à répliquer en
dénonçant des accusations hypocrite de
la part des américains et voici ce
qu'écrit libération sur le sujet
l'espace est un gigantesque champ de
bataille un traité de 1967 ambitionnait
de le démilitarisé loupe et
intimidations espionnage attaque directe
la liste ne relève pas de la science
fiction les dynamiques géopolitique sur
terre crée bel et bien des tensions au
delà de notre atmosphère et les enjeux
économiques en venir le tout en prouvant
qu'il peut cibler un satellite poutine
montre les muscles quand la france
développe sa stratégie spatiale de
défense la crise des missiles version
21e siècle ne se déroulera pas à cuba
mais dans le cosmos moscou accusé de
vouloir envahir l'ukraine et de jouer un
rôle majeur dans la crise migratoire à
la frontière polono biélorusse où des
milliers de personnes tentent au péril
de leur vie de gagner l'union européenne
pour la pologne c'est l'ombre de la
russie qui plane derrière le dirigeant
biélorusse alexandre loukachenko ne
serait en réalité que la marionnette de
vladimir poutine mais c'est vite oublier
la souveraineté de la biélorussie et le
caractère bouillant et imprévisible de
son président qui a même été désavouée
un publiquement par moscou il y a
quelques jours après avoir menacé de
couper l'arrivée de gaz aux occidentaux
en cas de nouvelles sanctions il s'agit
d'une déclaration du président de la
biélorussie je tiens tout de même à
rappeler la déclaration du président
poutine selon laquelle la russie a
toujours rempli ses obligations
contractuelles et que cela plaise ou non
à qui que ce soit la russie a toujours
été est et restera potentiellement un
pays garants de la sécurité énergétique
du continent européen il faut dire qu'on
a connu
marionnettes plus obéissante mais cela
ne fait pas les affaires des médias
mainstream france est bien décidée à
faire du président russe le coupable
parfait vladimir poutine montre une fois
de plus sa capacité de nuisance on le
retrouve dans tous les mauvais coups du
moment massant cent mille soldats aux
frontières de l'ukraine tirant les
ficelles de la biélorussie dans la crise
des migrants la russie poursuit tous
azimuts sa quête de puissance le kremlin
veut étendre sa zone d'influencé
reconquérir le terrain perdu après
l'effondrement de l'union soviétique
sur le continent européen
il mène une guerre hybride actionnant
des leviers militaire cybernétique
médiatique politique énergétique
migratoires cet activisme réveil de très
mauvais souvenirs les européens doivent
se serrer les coudes le rôle de méchant
l'art de la manipulation impose la loi
du plus fort c'est un sacré champ
lexical qu'a choisi le parisien pourra
décrire un chef d'état en exercice
pas sûr que beaucoup d'autres aient pu
bénéficier d'un éloge aussi fourni est
aussi soigné pour endosser le rôle du
méchant vladimir poutine est parfait cet
ancien du kgb n'a pas son pareil dans
l'art de la manipulation est excellent à
faire croire que la russie moderne dont
le pib n'atteint pas celui de l'italie
n'a rien perdu de l'empiré soviétique
qui régna jadis sur la moitié de la
planète au nom de quoi il un poste chez
lui et ailleurs de la crimée naguère
jusqu'à l'espace aujourd'hui la loi du
plus fort le problème est qu'en face il
n'y a guère de monde capable de jouer
les gentils et de résister au-delà des
remontrances formelle les américains ont
le regard ailleurs sur cette chine qui
les inquiète tant les européens pourtant
les premiers concernés par ces foyers
attisés sur leur sol ont comme
d'habitude du retard à l'allumage une
objectivité qui laisse sans voix quoique
tout n'est peut-être pas faux parce que
c'est vrai chez l'oncle sam le nouveau
grand méchant en chef qui monopolise
toutes les attentions se situe plus à
l'est dans l' empire du milieu et qu'en
europe en matière de retards à
l'allumage certains médias encore qu'on
sait dans la guerre froide font office
de champion